hello freak [ __ ] yeah he was a little
goofy but look man you figured out how
to dominate online sales I use
amazon.com all the time there's Kim and
the rock the rock was at the fights this
weekend
Oh give him a hug it's like hugging a
tree damn big tree I wonder how much
that dude ways with two big rock too big
bro he's he's in the 250 range for sure
yeah yeah for sure he's gigantic like
you don't realize how big he is until
you give him a hug the old friendly guy
but that guy gets bombarded man he can't
he can run anywhere without taking
pictures yeah they just they don't they
don't give a [ __ ] if you're talking to
him they get in between you they put
their paw hold their camera it's
ridiculous like people just they don't
give a [ __ ] about decorum or being
friendlies and then I'm getting this
[ __ ] picture with the rock it's my
one chance yeah they just swooped in man
anything for the grand man but it's
weird it's like all your normal
etiquette goes out the window like the
rock was sitting over there talking to
Demetrios Mighty Mouse Johnson mm-hmm
pound for pound best fighter in the
world no and they're talking back and
forth and having a good time and this
dude just swoops in between and one pops
up and it's like a picture bro go get a
picture bro and you know you see the
rock is always being friendly he's
amazing it staying friendly but you know
he's like god damn can't even talk to
the champ yeah yeah man I mean he wants
the followers he wants to yeah I guess
he's a nice guy he's a real nice guy
he's a real nice guy but that's giant
you're done bro you know needs to get
bigger nah man you think you think he's
done yes stop lifting yeah it's a
project right for the sculpture I mean
was he trying to go after this like
what's what's left well he's trying to
stay jacked and he's like 48 or some
[ __ ] how old was a rock I would say he's
about 42 take a week off no no you can't
that's the thing 45 so he's 45 and he's
act just ready jacked he's jacked he's
once keep that he's only one way you got
to do what he does that [ __ ]
every day he does he's uh he'll make
these videos when he shows up in places
like Germany he's gotta film some
[ __ ] movie he's there five o'clock in
the morning they already have an
elliptical machine in his in his in his
bed and his well in his hotel room he'll
get like a suite so they set up this
elliptical machine in his suite and he's
out there banging it out at five o'clock
in the morning doing an hour of cardio I
know him in a Kevin Hart videos bugged
me do you make you feel lazy just up
working out doing they've done more by
7:00 a.m. then I'm gonna do all day yeah
it's rude and they're trying to motivate
people like a man trying to sleep over
here bro
scroll up scroll up a little bit there
the one on the far right-hand side with
him pulling that rowing machine right
above that one that's doing some rows
that dudes gigantic that's a gigantic
person poor rowing machine does not
deserve this yeah but if you want to put
these things up and get how many
millions of views how many million views
that have six five million six hundred
thirty-nine thousand eight hundred
ninety-eight
views of him showing off doing polls we
get it you wake up in the morning but
he's motivating people sometimes like
you'll be sitting at home and feeling
like a lazy [ __ ] like I just want to
chill today I don't feel like working
and you go see the rock just get chains
wrapped around his neck chin ups the
entire thing yeah hitting tires with
missiles mhm yeah it's weird he's a
crazy man but those are the dudes that
like you need to know that like as hard
as you think you're working drop one
down from there that one was the other
one
I thought I want to jail yeah well look
at that right there you know as hard as
you think you're working you know
working down hard I know it was look at
that guy's
yeah so if you if you think you've done
everything you can to be prosperous in
this wife and you go to the rocks
Instagram and then shut your [ __ ]
hippie mouth and you'll [ __ ] your day up
[ __ ] it there this is what you didn't do
today and I know people like what hey
man I read a book today okay
hey man I've been writing poetry all day
hey man isn't writing songs
amen okay okay but have you put the same
amount of effort into being whatever you
want as the rock has done in being the
ultimate meathead whenever our Solaris
bar has got to change
do you know why you have changed makes
the end of the rep harder says as you
lift the chains up off the ground less
of the chains being supported by the
ground so it gets heavy and heavier as
you lift your hands up higher that's
called hardcore bro I don't know if you
boys are aware hardcore hardcore can get
that's so hardcore
that's how hardcore listen when I want
to feel bad about my day I just go to
the rocks Instagram
[Applause]
[Music]